let's get to it though because there
were a lot of things the owners did
yesterday and one significant thing they
did not do at least not for now
let's summarize and review the changes
that were made to expand the rooney rule
now for head coaching positions not just
one minority candidate must be
interviewed but two
double the existing standard that has
been in place for 18 years also there
must be at least one minority candidate
interviewed for each of the three
coordinator positions offensive
defensive and
special teams coordinator must be a
minority candidate interviewed for each
job one minority candidate for senior
football operations or gm jobs that's
been in place for a while that rule
specifically has not changed now
when talking about
non-football executive jobs teams must
include minority and or female
applicants for those positions club
presidents senior executives in various
positions outside the football realm but
part of the football operation an
important change here
something that many think has been
needed for a very long time team's no
longer allowed to block assistance from
interviewing for coordinator jobs so if
you can get a promotion elsewhere to a
coordinator the team can't say sorry
you're under contract we can't let you
go we're not letting you go you have to
stay here also expansion of minority
coaching fellowships with each team
creating a full-time position the key
though is this and all the other stuff
is great and we're going to talk about
it we're going to praise the league for
for doing what needs to be done to
enhance diversity in the national
football league but the biggest news out
of what happened on tuesday was the
decision to table
the measure that would have rewarded
teams for hiring
a coach or a gm with a minority
background that was controversial
but it felt like it was going to get
rammed through it felt like it was a
done deal it felt like it was going to
happen and here is roger goodell the
commissioner of the league and troy
vincent the executive vp of football
operations after yesterday's vote
explaining the tabling process and where
it goes from here
we table resolutions frequently
because the
the discussion leads to other ideas that
actually can make it even more effective
and so we've i think between art and i
and some other members of the committee
to talk to
virtually every club
there was a great deal of support but
there's also some suggestions amendments
and thoughts that
uh we may want to go back and talk to
others including the prince power
alliance and try to strengthen it just
to remind you all that
this won't go into effect into effect
until the end of the calendar year so
we hope that we will be meeting again in
person uh several times before there's
no rush for this
we got people's attention the
commissioner the chairman got people's
attention let's get this right there is
some value here coach dungy said it
right
we shouldn't be paying for people to do
the right thing
and there's the confirmation that coach
dungey was a very influential voice in
the process derailing what again many
thought was a done deal and look let's
let's be real on this
the measure doesn't get tabled if
there's 24 or more votes to pass it this
is what happens in lieu of saying we
voted and it failed guys so if they
would have taken a vote it would have
failed yesterday but they do want to
continue to talk about and that's all
that coach dungey and others were asking
for let's continue to have the
discussion about ways to go forward so
peter let me start with you your
thoughts on the decision not to go
forward with this measure that would
have created a specific reward for
hiring a minority coach or general
manager
well mike i
i never thought this was a done deal um
i know you and i spoke at one point over
the weekend and uh i you know the people
i talked to in the league
one of them who's very influential said
this one is too close to call
uh because there are people who feel
like you know what i wrote in my column
about louis riddick
so louis riddick the espn commentator
probably
has come as close
to anyone in the last two or three years
to getting a general manager's job who
didn't get it uh he came in number two
to dave gettleman with the giants in
december 2017.
and as he said to me he said look the
reason i don't like this is the first
day you walk in the building you're
gonna have people look at you and wonder
did they hire you because you're really
good at your job or did they hire you
because they get a draft advantage by
hiring you
and
although i'm not sure that's the way
people would think that's what louis
riddick thinks is the way people would
think
so i think that there are many
influential people around the nfl
who entered yesterday afternoon's
virtual uh meeting with all the owners
in the league basically saying look
if
the people who were really listening to
here
tony dungy and louis riddick
are adamantly opposed to this
those are probably right now
the two leading voices inside football
you know uh who are african-american
neither of them like it so why are we
doing this
and i kind of agree with that and look
whether it would have passed or not
passed i tend to think you're right mike
i don't think it would have passed
but
i do think that the smartest thing for
the league to do
is to go back and use the next three
four five weeks these guys are all just
sitting at home anyway and i don't mean
they're not doing anything else of
course they are
but they're sitting at home anyway
let's get a more
refined and refocused view of what this
rule should be
and then re-propose it either
at another league meeting you know
before the start of the year honestly
mike if somebody told me
we have
until the normal october fall meeting
to get all the t's crossed and all the
eyes dotted on a new rule uh
you know on a new rule that may
involve draft choice compensation
well listen i agree with you know all of
you louis riddick tony dungy yeah who's
better to listen to than those two they
got a great feel for the nfl and of
course their
african-american men who
have been in the league know what it
takes to be successful in the league
and also know what it will be to demean
or diminish an african-american coaching
candidate or one that does get a job
by this rule being set forth i just
think it would have caused more pro i
don't think it would have passed either
i mean i i agree with you guys i i just
think it would have uh really caused
more issues than been a positive thing
and i thought i think it would have
caused real resentment in the nfl
coaching world if that were to happen
too
so you know the big thing is i like a
lot of the steps that were made
yesterday i do think it's something in
the right direction but i think really
the genius of all this is the fact that
you know this where we are in this
conversation you know and i'm blanking
on the the the specific name mike that
through this
original idea out here about draft
compensation and things like that but
either way it was such a drastic you
know move we all our eyes lit up and
here we are we've been talking about it
for a few days and i think that's the
most important thing that now we're
going to get people's brains to stew and
you're going to have more conversations
and people are going to find better ways
to get something positive out of this
i think one of the keys here was coach
dungey speaking directly to individuals
in the league who have these high-level
jobs he told me on monday he talked to
african-american coaches in the league
what are your concerns about this and
they had multiple concerns the
perception when you do show up for the
first day on the job how other coaches
will view you will there be this sense
that the only reason you got the job was
because there was a reward out there and
i've heard the debate guys about well it
really isn't that much of a reward so it
really isn't going to influence behavior
why the hell is it on the table then the
mere fact that that's the reward the
mere fact that somebody decided you're
going to get a six-spot bump in round
three if you hire a minority coach or a
10-spot bump in round three if you hire
a minority general manager the fact that
they've identified that as the reward
for making that move shows it has value
otherwise they wouldn't do it so it
becomes a chicken in the egg thing very
quickly but they put it on the table and
anyone who hires a minority coach or gm
there's going to be
a normal conclusion by outsiders and
some insiders that that that was a
factor in all of that
the other thing that has been tabled
that i think
and i think this is where it's going to
end up peter i'm going to start with you
again on this when the dust settles on
this when they have a final vote in
october or whenever
the draft pick element is going to be
couched as compensation for teams that
have groomed and developed minority
coaches and lose them to coordinator
jobs or head coaching jobs elsewhere
that was part of this proposal it didn't
get a whole lot of attention because the
more controversial aspect did but i
think and reading between the lines
yesterday of the things said and not
said by roger goodell and troy vincent i
think the end result will be no reward
for actually hiring a minority coach or
gm you get compensation for losing a
minority assistant coach that you have
spent time developing who gets hired by
somebody else into a bigger role
yeah i mean
i i i
you know mike i've thought of that but
to me
that
although it is
significant
okay
that is not nearly as big as the other
proposal that did not get voted on uh
you know because
i'll tell you if if you lose a coach
that you have groomed and developed and
somebody says okay here whatever it's
decided on here's a fourth or fifth
round compensatory pick for that
i don't think anybody bats an eye on
that i really don't because
you know you are losing something you
know if if uh you know if the kansas
city chiefs lose eric b enemy to be a
head coach next year and they get a
fourth round compensatory pick and they
get the whatever it is 140th pick in the
draft
i mean i don't think anybody's going to
say well they didn't deserve that or
that's not right because
you know it just seems to me it kind of
seems fair you were the farm system to
develop that coach to be a head coach in
the nfl so
bill belichick retroactively i'm not
saying that they will should get a
fourth round pick for developing brian
flores and you know the miami dolphins
uh you know hiring him to be a head
coach the other one is so much more
significant to me
because of what it carries with it
and that is the stigma that the only way
you hired me
is because
not the only way
but the a predominant reason why you
hired me is because
i'm african-american and if it's a
general manager position you can improve
from let's just say
you know 70 to 60 in the draft and and
that's a that's a big chunk in my
opinion
well yeah that obviously is the more
lightning rod conversation uh but i
think in a lot of ways mike this is
something that you and i talked about a
lot yesterday you know i i do like the
the compensatory picks for
yes grooming an african-american coach
having them come up through your system
and then losing them yeah i think that
gives teams a little bit of incentive to
you know delve down that tunnel a little
bit more that they don't do enough right
now so to me i like that aspect of it i
i do i i think it really and again
there's some other things here i know
we're going to talk about but i do think
it has to start at that root level that
very base entry level
for a lot of these teams and especially
for minority african american coaches if
we want to see
more of them throughout the league in gm
jobs and head coaching jobs we just got
to see more of them involved in the
football business in general and like i
said yesterday it's just very hard to
get into this secret society coaching
football world i mean hey you know my
dad won a super bowl played 15 years you
know i
hey dad can you call a few teams hey dad
dad i called i've called a few teams
nobody got back to me you know i mean it
doesn't matter you have to have serious
connections and work a lot of pipelines
and that's why we see so many family
members and like we said like people who
know the owner and know the gm and their
sons are working in the building so
that's where i like the compensatory
pick idea for grooming african-american
coaches it gets them in the building and
gives teams incentives to do that
and really from the standpoint of where
this all goes from here if there isn't
support for the reward for hiring a
minority coach or gm what will the final
product look like and i base my
assessment on a question that was posed
to the commissioner yesterday by jared
bell of usa today who said how do you
reconcile the concept of a reward with
a disadvantage to other teams who get
leap frogged in the draft process by
teams that have gotten this six spot
bump this 10 spot bump and the
commissioner's response focused on the
concept of compensation for losing a
coach didn't say anything at all about
this notion of rewarding a team that
hires a minority coach or gm a very
subtle but i think a very real
indication as to where the ball is
moving and and i think that at the end
of the day
they're not going to do it peter i think
your read on it this notion that there
will be a perception and perception can
be reality that
even though it isn't some great reward
it's not a first-round pick it's not an
extra 30 million dollars in cap space or
something like that it's just a bump in
round three it's enough that it will
cause problems for the men who get these
jobs as they walk through the door and
they may be thinking from the get-go
that that the only reason or not the
only reason but the tiebreaker the last
reason there was some advantage
cultivated by giving me the job as
opposed to a non-minority and and that
just isn't the way that you want to
start a job like this you want to start
a job like this in a positive way
feeling like you were the best person
for the job that you earned this spot
that there was no artificial incentive
that was available by hiring you that
wasn't available by hiring someone else
so peter i think your read on it's on
the money and if i had to predict now
i'd say this thing is dead it's gone and
we're never going to hear from it again
mike remember back in february and march
when
dee smith was
you know fighting with uh with his own
union basically to try to get the new
cba passed
and i just kept thinking to myself
what is wrong with this picture
you know
d smith has been negotiating
with the league and he got a deal along
with you know his
many and his board and a couple notably
who didn't want it but he's been
negotiating and fighting to get this
deal and now his own players don't want
it many of them
don't want it you know as i reported at
the time it was the equivalent of
30 players
in every locker room
30 3-0 who did not want this deal and
yet it passed but
it reminded me
when i was thinking about this i said
you know what would be really odd about
this
if the nfl passes this rule
and troy vincent roger goodell said
we're doing something for the equality
of the african-american coaches
and for the candidates who would be
general managers in front offices
and then so now
espn sports center goes to tony dungy
and says what do you think coach and
they go to louis riddick in in his box
from his home and they both said this is
a sham i hate it it stinks you know so
that's one of the reasons now why
i think they got to find something else
to try to fix it
yeah they got to find something else i
mean we talked about it it's it's
demeaning almost it's it's a stupid idea
really and listen you know hey guys
we've all been around like mike tomlin
and anthony lynn right two of the the
best african american coaches in the
league two really awesome coaches in
general they're no nonsense no bs in
your face work hard they did everything
right to get that job they don't want to
walk into a building and have that
stigma over them or somebody that's like
them in the future to have that stigma
of hey we gave your you know i'm here
because my team got a reward yeah i did
some good things but the reward really
got it done no that's that's where it's
bad and i think that's where roger
goodell avoided kind of talking in that
that language yesterday that you talked
about mike and referred to because i
think they realize it's it's not the
right road to go down here with this
conversation
all right and it will again be taken up
there'll be more discussion more
conversation my prediction though is
that the specific reward for hiring a
minority coach or gm that's done the
compensation angle i think will
re-emerge and will be put in place and
also look
this is just the first step they are
going to revolutionize the hiring
process that's something else tony dungy
told me on monday delaying the start of
the hiring process that's coming other
steps are coming this was just the first
one it was a big one one big angle of it
was left out but more is to come over
the next year or two in this revolution
of the hiring process the notion that
teams will not be allowed
to prevent assistant coaches from
interviewing for promotions elsewhere
look there was a time years ago where
teams could
not stand in the way of a guy who was
getting a promotion on a coaching staff
with another team they changed the rules
to force these guys to stay put there
have been some teams that have been
notorious about it you're under contract
we're not going to let you interview for
a job elsewhere unless it's a head
coaching job even if it's a promotion
now that goes away this has been needed
by the nfl regardless of the race of the
candidate it's just a fairness issue let
guys
pursue opportunities
to enhance their careers it's all about
upward mobility if you're doing a good
job and someone else notices it and they
want to they want to hire you for a
bigger job then you should be allowed to
go seek that bigger job it's that simple
chris so you know i'm i'm glad they
finally got to the point where they
needed to be
however it took to get there as part of
an expansion of the rooney rule whatever
they've finally done the right thing
here and gotten rid of this ability for
teams to squat on guys who could be
making more money having more authority
and further developing their career by
going to a different team
you're right i mean you're squatting on
guys careers you know and sometimes for
a coach you know you get on you you've
worked hard for let's say 15 or 20 years
now you got two or three years of
success and things are going in the
right direction you want to get
interviewed by a team right and all of a
sudden you get blocked oh and now the
team that you're working for starts to
fall apart and now you never have that
chance to go get an interview again you
got to almost you know rework your magic
and you know get
get the perception out there that you're
worthy of an interview again so yes
that's what you know squatting on guys
or blocking them from interviewing let
alone mike it really ultimately hurts
the lead it does because it keeps some
of the best candidates and the best
minds and the people that might be you
know best for the job
not in the conversation you know just
because the guy you know he's been
blocked maybe he's the most qualified
guy maybe he's a genius that's been
under a sean payton or bill belichick
for a long long time but they've gave
him a tough title and now he can't go
interview because this next job isn't
enough of a bump up or whatever it may
be all those things were stupid and i
think ultimately hurt the
the ability of the league to get the
best and most creative coaches to be the
head coaches and make our game better
and more fun
look i i i
i just want you to imagine how
and look this is not the biggest thing
in the world but think about how history
might have been changed this year just a
little bit okay
philadelphia eagles doug peterson who's
the coach of the eagles
wants to interview mike kafka as his
offensive coordinator okay mike kafka is
the quarterback coach
in kansas city uh he's been great
in kansas city he's a rising star the
way andy reid does his coaching staff
honestly
is that he prepares guys
and and kind of grooms guys to take that
next step he did it with doug peterson
became the eagles head coach in 2016.
2017 matt nagy becomes the head coach of
the
chicago bears and now in 2019 at the end
of 19 he wants eric b enemy really to
you know fly out of the nest
and become a head coach somewhere that
didn't happen but he had mike kafka
ready
to ascend to the offensive coordinator
job in kansas city he did not want to
lose kafka because he is next in line to
be the offensive coordinator
so andy reid can stop him under the old
rules
okay and he prevents him from uh going
to philadelphia and interviewing for the
oc job now they give him
uh you know a better title passing game
coordinator now but really it it really
doesn't change a lot of things in the
day-to-day life of mike kafka's job he
just got a better title and probably a
little bit more money
but that is what the difference now is
whereas the eagles could have had my
kafka a year later had they so chosen
you know they don't get him and kafka
has to stay back in kansas city that is
where this rule is really going to
impact teams in 2020 and beyond
and the only argument i ever heard
against the uh or in support rather of
this ability to squad on assistance is
hey hey if if you if you want to have
mobility only sign one-year contracts in
other words when you sign a multi-year
deal you have security in the event that
everybody is fired well the other side
of the coin of that security is you're
stuck here now you've signed a
three-year contract or a four-year
contract whatever the case may be
but you know what a lot of teams won't
give you a one-year contract if you want
one and it's just not a good way to do
business having guys on one-year
contracts i mean the bottom line is if
there are individuals who are in a
position where they can advance their
careers and you're not in a position to
give them that promotion and someone
else is then
you wish them the best and you have
faith in your ability to reload the
organization underneath that guy who has
departed and for the chiefs who
constantly have the confidence they can
reload the offensive coordinator
position well they're going to have to
reload positions even lower on the totem
pole so be it that's what teams are
going to have to be ready to do chris
yeah well that's right you know and hey
you squat on a coach and do that like it
might be the only opportunity that guy
has to make a big move in his career so
yeah you're ruining a lot livelihoods
that way and i understand you know
somewhat of why the rule was in place
but you know bigger picture too you know
and i think one of the big reasons we're
in this whole conversation right now and
with the minority coaching candidates
too is just a subject that just you know
kind of came up organically here which
is the kansas city chiefs and i think
this is really the root of the problem
and why we're like at a point with this
conversation right now you know i don't
know you tell me how do the optics look
let's see doug peterson offensive
coordinator kansas city chiefs for two
years gets a head coaching job matt nagy
offensive coordinator for two years gets
a head coaching job huh eric the enemy
offensive coordinator of the chiefs two
years offense is the best in football
and explodes and has the quarterback
whisperer effect and doesn't get a job
and doesn't even really in
like high demand or command or anything
like that that to me and again i'm not
accusing anybody of anything but i think
that's why we are where we are right now
the optics of that do not look right and
we need more diversity and sorry it just
kind of came up to me there i didn't
mean to like totally change the subject
but you guys kind of went down that road
and led me there and i couldn't help it
i think it makes sense i think it's a
legitimate point peter the idea that
because eric b enemies
failure to get an nfl head coaching job
has become so glaring that's one of the
main reasons why they've taken this step
back and said we've got to do something
because it makes sense to no one that
eric b enemy is not yet a head coach
somewhere
you know and the other part of it mike
that i think the nfl and i know that
they're thinking about this now
is that i think the nfl really needs to
very seriously consider
pushing back the hiring process and the
hiring period until after the super bowl
this is not just a 2020 thing this has
been an every year thing it is totally
ridiculous that you get penalized
for your team being really good and for
you doing a great job
okay and what i mean by that is that
most jobs are spoken for
by the time the super bowl is over okay
and to me it's categorically unfair
just categorically unfair look at some
of the rising stars who've just been
ignored look at arthur smith with the
tennessee titans
everybody starts saying oh my god look
at this tennessee offense look at the
passing game even they haven't had a
passing game you know with marcus
mariota it was just fits and starts
and they've managed to merge the running
game and the passing game better
much better than under matt lafleur and
he just went 13-3 with the with the
green bay packers
so you know to me
wait
press the pause button and on february
5th
start the process
no interviews until february 5th if you
cheat you get penalized to draft choice
that is why i think or that is the way
you can make it a level playing field
for everyone
yeah coach dungey says that that is
coming i've heard from others it is
coming the only challenge will be for
the teams that don't make it to the
playoffs the bad teams that from a pr
standpoint want to show their fan base
that they are pointing in the right
direction they're not going to want to
wait a month
while they otherwise would be going out
there and bringing to the fan base
here's the new shiny object here's the
new coach that's going to turn us around
but maybe everyone would what if you
can't introduce that shiny object what
what if you can't introduce that shiny
object for a month
what i mean that's the problem so
washington had a solution to this we're
going to hire a guy who's out of who's
out of work
and and so we're going to hire ron
rivera okay so they got their guy and
maybe if it was a month later they still
would have hired ron rivera i assume
they would have
but for the most part
all you can do is make informal
agreements with these guys anyway you
can't introduce them
okay so to me
in my opinion the way that you have to
do this the way that you have to do this
honestly
is you have to make it fair for
everybody and that means fair for every
team and fair for every coach in the
process
all right uh and again that is still to
come in the coming months and years
sooner than later though they i think
they will be pushing back the start of
the hiring process when the season ends
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports